il y à fond de mon jardin un bac à
compost je vous en parle aujourd'hui pas
uniquement parce que c'est le deuxième
jour de confinement mais parce que c'est
la journée internationale du recyclage
depuis des années je dépose mes déchets
verts les épluchures le marc de café les
essuie-tout alors c'est vrai qu'en
surface
c'est pas très ragoûtant mais après
plusieurs mois de confinement quand les
micro organismes ont dégradé les déchets
eh bien on obtient une matière recyclée
très agréable au toucher je vais
l'utiliser pour enrichir le sol de mon
petit jardin et en plus ça sent sous
bois une vraie capsule 2d confiné aller
à demain et surtout n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés nous reste en lien même
formule tiers je recycle
si vous avez aimé cette capsule 2d
confiné n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle chaque
jour alors pour ne pas les rater
abonnez-vous et activer la cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain